here comes brady singer maneuvering
through the cameraman
making start number six his third
against the indians he's had two very
good starts
against the tribe in the past should
give him some confidence coming in
one ball two strikes with two down salvi
sets up inside and a strikeout
so singer is sharp in the first with his
fastball
and the indians are down in order bieber
coming out making his seventh start came
off a win against the
chicago white sox had one start against
kansas city earlier it was his only no
decision of the year and he's 4-0 in his
career against him
last year's best pitcher in major league
baseball shane bieber will face
wit murryfield that is off of jose
ramirez glove
and he recovers and throws it away
whit hustles for second and the royals
get a break
to begin the bottom of the first inning
how about it put the ball in play
just got through telling you he didn't
he didn't throw anything in the middle
and he did there
first inning let's see what they can do
here field moves up 90 feet to third
and carlos antana now coming up against
his former teammate fastball and he blew
it by him
right on the outside edge a nice high
heater made him go after it away
69th strikeout of the year for bieber
yeah
not he could he couldn't do anything
with it
yep struck him out on three pitches to
end the inning
so shane bieber picks up jose ramirez
bieber has never lost to the royals
getting more done and that describes
hunter dozier recently and that is
crushed deep left center field hunter
dozier goes deep to give the royals the
lead
my oh my does he have
some loud swings when he barrels look at
that that looks like a fastball or
could have been a cutter not really sure
exactly what that was
but it was sent a long way
beautiful start for dozier
and the royals they'll take the lead
yeah the 1-2
struck him out looking with a fastball
boy was that big for bieber
gets that second out of the inning and
now a chance to get out of it without
any further damage
if he can get the top of the order
hitter in whit merrifield
one-two pitch god i'm looking with a
fastball in the outside corner and shane
bieber
strikes out two more chance to answer
right back now for cleveland after the
bottom of the order gets him a start
and it is a fastball over the inside
edge
hernandez argues with angel hernandez
but it was very close to that
inner boundary and there are two down
yep
blue kc pitch track shows you where that
pitch was on the inside part of the
plate
and that's in the left field deep but
playable
and that is the inning so brady singer
pitches around
first and third in one out bieber's
ready check
second comes to the plate swing and a
miss
fastball running up and away and he got
him again
five strikeouts for bieber he has struck
out santana with a runner at third
one out and now struck out santana with
a runner at second nobody up
royals want to come up with at least one
here from the fourth
runners go and late throw to second
they got him oh baby and he threw from
his knees that's a heads up play by
hedges
hedges looked at third but thought he
had a better chance at second and he
throws out taylor
that's back to the middle but jimenez is
there
and it's in the dirt
ryan o'hearn scores on a throwing air by
jimenez on a routine ground ball
and the royals lead two-nothing how
about it they'll take
a break man oh man are you kidding
it's beautiful you know bowers did all
he could there and bieber saying
uh-oh he's at third with two down
and hedges strikes out
and that's five scoreless innings for
brady singer
you kind of foresaw him having one of
these tough starts because of the
fatigue of having these tough starts
previously he's had some big matchups
with number one guys
solaire twice tonight
has grounded sharply to short
there we go into the gap left center
and up against the wall then intend he
scores salvi's around third he'll score
and jorge soler it's a two-run double
and the royals lead
four nothing and listen to the sweet
music of the crowd
well that's a clutch hit and he
shortened up his swing and swung at
about
75 80 percent just like what we just
what we were talking about
it's a slider and he made a mistake he
hung it but look how controlled the
swing was he even had a takeoff at one
hand takeoff
yeah there you go just meet the ball
look at how easy that ball jumped
and for sure salvador perez with a good
read
but from first base says i'm scoring i
want to get dirty a little bit here too
it's four nothing royals here's the
pitch
breaking ball swung out and missed so
dozier is down on strikes
two down in the inning that's the sixth
strikeout for
bieber struck him out
he gets his seventh strikeout of the
night but the royals get
two here in the fifth to open up a four
nothing lead
[Applause]
and the bat goes flying and angel
hernandez is going to say that it hit
his jersey
now ramirez did not react as if it had
hit him
and mike matheny says wait a minute
let's take another look at that
nothing new and the royals are going to
challenge
they're saying boy that i don't know
about that
because by looking at that replay the
only contact
the only contact possible contact is
with the bat
you have the knob there is no way no way
[Applause]
you can make an argument that that hit
the jersey
or the hand that should be an out wow
[Applause]
that ball is hitting the air deep left
center field that's in the gap that's
going to get down and go to the wall
scoring his powers ramirez right on his
heels that wave him home as well
eddie rosario delivers with a long
two run double to center field to get
the indians on the board
and they've cut the lead in half well
you slowed it down for eddie and he took
you to left center field
and i got to tell you it's their own
fault you walk the first guy you hit the
second guy you leave a spinner up and he
does a nice job
he's going to stay with zinger with two
on and one out
and a pick off play at second base
almost got him
and they're gonna call a bach and this
might get explosive
cal eldridge is all over angel hernandez
from the first base dugout
and so that was that was directed at cal
and now you got two enormous men
coming out at angel hernandez
and now mike matheny has been thrown out
there was a little shift yeah he had
little little uh
shift in his legs before he actually
turned and moved
ground ball nice stop at first santana
will take the out it's a one-run game as
eddie rosario scores
thanks to the buck yeah how much did
that help now
now brady singer gets into it with angel
hernandez
so he was ejected
did he go they appeal he did
bieber gets his eighth strikeout so the
streak continues for shane bieber
that is now 19 consecutive games
with at least eight strikeouts well he
bounced this one or
and you can see it was close the right
hander is ready
here it comes a swing and a miss curve
in the dirt
hedges picks it up tags out lopez nine
strikeouts for shane bieber including
the last four royals here's captain
clutch jose ramirez over two
ramirez swings drives one deep right
this ball
gone into the royal bullpen
and he's given up another blast jose
ramirez
ties the game at four and the indians
coming from behind
again in the late endings josh naylor
leans it off
and the payoff pitch and it's swung on
and hammered to right
down the line it goes gone
and the indians have a 5-4 lead
and wade davis just got beat
with a pool side homer incredible
27 strikeouts in 13 innings
for karen check who has already saved
two games this year
and a ground ball to short jimenez
he throws on the money book it the
indians have won the first three in
kansas city
they run their win streak overall to
four in a row
and they have now won eight of their
last 10.